the cynicism safety blanket cynicism is
a guarded response which sets yourself
up against disappointment its role
within the system is to protect you
against experiencing anything bad it is
a preemptive strike against a perceived
threat if I tell myself that all women
are bad then I'm less likely to seek
relationship with women and as a
consequence I'm never going to feel the
pain of rejection if I tell myself that
everything is things will never get
better then I'm excused of ever having
to try it anything the cope is framing
hope is pathetic and embarrassing and
optimism is delusion the upside of never
trying is never having to feel the pain
of failure that's so good that is so
many people in our society right now so
many young people so many in my
generation specifically